Traduttore: Marco Raja
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Oggi cominciamo da un albero:
un albero di noce, in particolare.
Il noce è un albero molto nobile,
molto prezioso.
Dal noce si ottengono frutti,
si ottiene un liquore anche;
si ottiene anche un combustibile,
dall'olio e naturalmente,
dopo molti anni, si può ottenere
anche del prezioso legname;
legname che, ad esempio, storicamente,
nei secoli, è stato utilizzato
nella città di Venezia
per costruire le forcole.
Le forcole, che sono quegli oggetti
che sostengono i remi,
nelle gondole
e in altre imbarcazioni tradizionali
e che sono costruite da maestri,
come il mio amico Saverio,
che tramandano
di generazione in generazione
delle pratiche, delle esperienze
che vengono appunto da assai lontano.
È stato proprio Saverio a raccontarmi
una storia interessante,
una tradizione che ha a che fare
proprio con il noce.
Nelle campagne venete si usava piantare
un noce quando nasceva un bambino piccolo.
Era una sorta di immaginazione del futuro;
era, se vogliamo, costruire,
in qualche maniera,
il futuro di questo bambino che nasceva,
ma non solo suo, anche dei suoi figli
perché, insomma, un noce, prima,
ad esempio, di diventare utilizzabile
per falegnameria richiede 60-70 anni,
e questa pratica, questo pensiero,
questa ispirazione
di pensare al futuro, ai nostri figli
è qualcosa che ci accomuna,
oggigiorno addirittura per taluni
anche in maniera drammatica,
pensando a chi per esempio
è costretto ad arrivare al dramma
di lasciare i propri figli
in mani di qualcun altro,
perché magari attraversino un mare
per abbandonare paesi in guerra
o in povertà.
Eppure, accade anche che noi
oggi qui, nei nostri ricchi paesi,
questi noci non li piantiamo più.
Anzi, in gran parte li abbiam tagliati;
negli anni '60 -'70
c'è stato un uso indiscriminato
e non facciamo più questa operazione,
quest'operazione di immaginare il futuro.
Ed effettivamente è un bel problema;
un bel problema
perché non solo non lo immaginiamo,
ma in qualche maniera lo subiamo.
Peggio ancora,
lo facciamo subire agli altri.
Ci sono molti esempi
che si potrebbero fare,
ma pensiamo, ad esempio,
al tema dell'ambiente.
Entro pochi decenni si dice che avremo
più plastica che pesci nel mare;
oppure, pensiamo anche all'ambiente inteso
come clima in cui viviamo;
l'uso indiscriminato
che stiamo facendo dell'energia;
lo spreco di risorse
che la natura ha impiegato,
veramente, magari centinaia, migliaia,
se non milioni di anni per realizzare.
Bene, noi forse dovremmo cercare
di essere più attenti, anzi senza forse,
senz'altro e per fare questo
la ricerca scientifica ci può aiutare,
perché la ricerca scientifica
ha un po' in comune
con la storia del noce, no?
Perché tante volte si pianta un seme
senza ben sapere cosa succederà,
o comunque sapendo
che le cose verranno molto,
i risultati verranno
molto molto in là nel tempo.
È il caso di Heinrich Hertz,
per esempio,
il primo fisico che ha rivelato
le onde elettromagnetiche,
previste qualche anno prima da Maxwell,
Hertz nel 1887,
e lui non sapeva bene
a cosa sarebbero servite,
lo disse anche: "è una prova
della teoria del maestro Maxwell,
ma non ho ben idea di quali saranno
le loro applicazioni".
Eppure oggi sappiamo che,
solo per fare un paio di esempi fra tanti,
le onde elettromagnetiche
sono alla base di moltissimi aspetti
della nostra società:
pensiamo alle comunicazioni,
giusto per dirne una,
ma anche, giusto per fare
un altro esempio, alla cura,
la cura dei tumori, per esempio,
che si fa con microonde, no?
E quindi, la ricerca scientifica
è proprio, in molti casi,
un immaginare il futuro
piantando un seme di noce.
Accade anche oggi,
è notizia proprio di qualche giorno fa
che sta per partire la realizzazione
di un nuovo grande miglioramento
dell'acceleratore LHC,
che fra una decina, una quindicina d'anni
ci permetterà di esplorare nuove frontiere
della fisica, della materia,
delle interazioni fondamentali.
Chi lo costruisce oggi forse magari
neanche lo vedrà in operazione,
o comunque non vedrà tutti i risultati
che potrà ottenere.
E allo stesso modo
anche noi, anch'io stesso,
in qualche maniera, nella mia attività
di ricerca mi occupo di qualcosa
che va forse oltre addirittura
la mia aspettativa di vita:
il tentativo di portare sulla Terra
un pezzo di Sole,
ovvero riprodurre in laboratorio
la fusione dell'idrogeno.
È un problema che nasce
da una necessità impellente;
vi citavo prima il discorso
della questione energetica.
Immaginare un futuro significa anche
immaginare un futuro sostenibile
dal punto di vista energetico per i nostri
figli, per le generazioni future.
Quello che stiamo avendo oggi
certamente non lo è;
la fusione può dare una risposta,
può dare un contributo fondamentale,
da questo punto di vista. Perché?
Beh, intanto vediamo cos'è la fusione.
In sostanza è un processo tutto sommato
elementare, attraverso il quale
due nuclei leggeri, due nuclei di isotopi
dell'idrogeno si fondono uno con l'altro
e producono un neutrone e dell'elio,
e in questo riarrangiamento
della struttura nucleare della materia,
si libera energia.
Energia che poi può essere trasformata
in energia elettrica
ed ha una serie di pregi notevoli.
Intanto è un processo
intrinsecamente libero da CO2;
non si usano combustibili fossili;
si basa su un combustibile
sostanzialmente illimitato:
acqua, da cui si ottiene
il deuterio e litio,
ampiamente presente
nella crosta terrestre,
da cui si ottiene poi il trizio.
È intrinsecamente sicura, non ha questi,
proprio per natura,
non tanto per scelta dell'uomo.
Non dà luogo
a scorie radioattive di lunga durata.
Non espone a rischi
di proliferazione degli armamenti,
quindi, senza dubbio è una fonte
che ha notevoli vantaggi,
oltre a quello di darci
la possibilità di costruire,
insieme alle rinnovabili,
insieme all’immagazzinamento dell'energia,
delle fonti concentrate che consentono
ad esempio lo sviluppo
di un'economia dei trasporti
basata, per esempio, sull'elettricità.
Bene, voi direte,
allora è fatta; in realtà, no.
Non è ancora fatta. È un po' difficile,
una delle difficoltà fondamentali
è che questi due nuclei
che vogliamo far fondere,
in realtà non amano molto
fondersi tra loro
perché sono carichi positivamente,
quindi tenderebbero a respingersi;
e noi, per cercare di vincere questa loro
naturale tendenza, li riscaldiamo.
Li riscaldiamo molto, a temperature
che sono addirittura
maggiori delle temperature al centro
del Sole - 100 milioni e più
di gradi centigradi - a queste temperature
questi nuclei acquistano
velocità estremamente elevate,
si scontrano l'uno con l'altro
e in questo scontro possono avvicinarsi
a distanze tali da poter far sì
che la repulsione elettrostatica
venga invece vinta dalla forza attrattiva,
dall'interazione attrattiva nucleare.
Ecco, questo è quello
che noi cerchiamo di fare.
Naturalmente il problema è cercare
di realizzare una bottiglia, una scatola
che possa contenere un pezzo di Sole.
E anche questo, naturalmente,
scientificamente, tecnologicamente,
non è per nulla banale;
abbiamo imparato a farlo abbastanza bene
utilizzando dei campi magnetici.
Sono in sostanza delle ciambelle toroidali
in cui disegniamo,
introduciamo dei campi magnetici
e questi campi magnetici
sono in grado di tenere
il nostro combustibile
lontano dalle pareti materiali
del contenitore e quindi tenerlo
insieme in una porzione di spazio limitata
dove possiamo usarlo proprio per cercare
di ottenere l'energia che ci serve.
Bene, questa storia
è una lunga storia di ricerca.
Ha quasi l'età
di un noce, di un noce adulto.
Nasce dopo la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
nei primi anni ‘50.
Uno dei protagonisti è Andrei Sakharov,
forse qualcuno lo ricorda,
vince il premio Nobel per la pace
ed è stato anche un grandissimo fisico.
Proprio a lui si deve,
insieme al suo collega Tamm,
uno dei primi lavori
che identificano il tokamak,
che è una di queste configurazioni
che noi usiamo.
Dall'epoca si è fatta molta strada.
Abbiamo fatto errori,
siamo tornati indietro;
abbiamo avuto
anche tantissimi bei risultati,
abbiamo fatto grandi spinte in avanti,
ripensamenti;
insomma un po' l'evoluzione
classica della scienza.
Da quel seme che han piantato
i nostri maestri decenni fa
abbiamo fatto tanta strada
anche qui in Italia.
Per esempio, questo che vedete
è l'esperimento RFX
a Padova, dove ho lavorato per molti anni,
e che è uno degli esperimenti
protagonisti della storia
ma anche oggi dell'attualità
nella ricerca sulla fusione.
E sempre qui in Italia tra poco,
anzi proprio in queste settimane,
abbiamo cominciato la progettazione
di un nuovo grande esperimento,
che verrà realizzato in Italia
e si direbbe completamente
"Made in Italy";
si chiama DTT (Divertor Test
Tokamak), e in qualche maniera
rappresenterà per noi e anche soprattutto
per le generazioni che verranno,
per i miei studenti di oggi, ma anche
per gli studenti dei miei studenti,
un po' il futuro e che dovrà dare
un importante aiuto
per quello che è un po'
il nostro scopo fondamentale,
cioè quello di realizzare infine
un esperimento, un reattore
che possa produrre dall'idrogeno,
dalla fusione dell'idrogeno, elettricità.
Un passo fondamentale sarà quindi ITER.
ITER, che è questo esperimento
che stiamo costruendo
nel sud della Francia,
molto più grande anche di DTT,
a cui contribuiscono sette grandi realtà
come l'Unione Europea, gli Stati Uniti,
il Giappone, la Cina,
l'India, la Corea, la Russia,
e che comincerà le sue attività
fra circa una decina d’anni
e avrà il compito proprio di dimostrare
che la fusione
è scientificamente fattibile
e sarà seguito poi
da un reattore sperimentale
che si chiamerà DEMO.
Allora è chiaro che, come vi dicevo,
torniamo al nostro albero,
è chiaro che questa è una ricerca
che si è sviluppata
e si sviluppa lungo parecchi decenni.
Quando avremo energia
elettrica dalla fusione?
Una domanda
che spesso mi viene rivolta.
Ce l'avremo direi,
ormai siamo abbastanza consapevoli,
forse in passato i maestri
sono stati un po' troppo ottimisti;
oggi siamo un po' più certi dei tempi,
conosciamo le difficoltà
e credo che sia abbastanza tranquillo
poter dire che avremo
energia elettrica da fusione
nella seconda metà di questo secolo.
Certo, si potrebbe anche far prima,
se ci fosse veramente una volontà
anche da parte dei nostri amministratori
di investire di più, ma tant’è, insomma,
il problema è complesso e quindi questo
arriverà nella seconda metà del secolo.
È senz'altro oltre
la mia aspettativa di lavoro
e probabilmente anche
oltre la mia aspettativa di vita
e quindi mi viene naturale
col passare degli anni
anche chiedermi
se ne vale la pena, no?
Perché mi accorgo che questa cosa
va un po' oltre,
e alla fine mi rispondo di sì,
certamente,
perché anche a me, insomma,
piace l'idea di essere anch'io
una di queste persone che hanno aiutato
a piantare questo piccolo seme
che mi auguro un domani
possa diventare un grande noce
e contribuire a risolvere
questa grande questione energetica.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
[Musica]